because i've tried to poke fun at
being a dumb kid right that's what i
mean whenever i've done that
it gets twisted into i'm talking [ __ ]
about somebody
who i don't even know anymore who's
clearly a grown-up like
right but i'm i i think
you have to like laugh at who you used
to be but when people ask me about
um history that involves someone else
right
i unfortunately like i just well it's
not even unfortunate
it's just not work it's not worth my
time right it's not a place where i
harbor
um you know ill will or
and it can't come out right it never
does right right
and i've tried to like you know do the
thing where when i get
stuck uh live on the air which has
happened to me twice
getting asked about it where i like give
a little like huh like jazz hands quip
and move on
and it doesn't it just doesn't work so
i'm not going to i
i you know i was a very um
naive 21 year old kid well i think that
you you said something where you want
when you got married you go and
get married because you think you're
gonna be married once michael we're not
really gonna talk about this are we no
i'm just thinking i think that though
that's why i'm single
the reason i brought it up hear me out
okay is because i think
i've seen so much dysfunction in my
family you have it maybe i think every
family has seen
i've seen extreme dysfunction
dysfunction my sister's married five
times
wow mother three times a lot of
different things so i
feel that [ __ ] man i'm not getting
married until it's the one
and that might sound naive but that's
why i think i've waited so long
yeah i get that but you know what i
think
look i think lots of people do stupid
[ __ ] before their prefrontal cortexes
are fully formed and they're not until
they're 26. right so you do the math on
my timeline i literally didn't have a
whole brain
so i have like humor and grace for like
being a kid and you know
having the experience that i had but but
i also think
we're at a really interesting time where
we're look we're looking at systems in
general
and marriage i learned so much about it
reading elizabeth gilbert's book
committed
and one of the things i thought was so
interesting and i read it years ago so i
won't have the facts perfect for you
which i like to but here we are but she
essentially talks about how
early or there's early evidence of the
church trying to ban marriage
because you were not as you know a
member of the faithful
supposed to be devoted to anyone but god
and then they realized they couldn't
keep people
from getting married people in villages
and towns were just doing this thing so
then they said
the only recognized marriage is in the
church so
we have to look at what our motivations
are what the politics are
um churches by the way are so political
it's crazy to me they don't pay taxes
again separate conversation
um but you know it used to be
that the the person on this farm and the
person on this farm would get married so
they could join farms and there was a
dowry and somebody got like livestock
and
like really weird patriarchal nonsense
and now we're in this time where as many
if not more women in
our country anyway are the breadwinners
of their household um
people want to build families they want
to have kids they want to have
these experiences that i think we all
deeply
romanticize and you look at a divorce
rate of over 50 percent
it's really complicated um you know it's
something like and this was a stat i
read a few years ago
so i'd be curious to know if the numbers
are the same now but 72 percent of men
cheat on their wives
followed by 41 wait how many 72 percent
of men cheat on their own if i remember
the stat correctly and followed by and
growing 41
of women who are now cheating on their
husbands i know we're just talking about
heteronormative relationships but that's
the stat that i read
and that number is growing as more and
more women become
the economic leaders of their households
and so
i think overall we have to have a much
more real conversation
as a society and within our own romantic
relationships and
our friendships with you know our
friends who are likely in romantic
relationships of their own
what are our motivations like what are
we looking for
i i grew up on disney movies and
watching rom-coms i went to an all-girls
school
i was the prime like right out of the
cartoon factory candidate for like a
fairy tale ideal of young love come on
like it wrote itself